he's Adam Schefter he's of ESPN senior
NFL analyst and host of the Adam
Schefter podcast we just played a clip
of Adam I believe back in September when
he talked to Gronk about that
possibility of coming back and Adam
joins us on the program Adam when did
you start to get wind that Gronk was
indeed ready to come back well the funny
thing is I will tell you this Dan about
a month ago just passing our baseball
insider if I could
texted me that he was told drunk is
coming back and I made some calls and it
was kind of poo pooed at the time but
also got word that there are a lot of
players that were contacting Tampa that
wanted to come play for Tom it was not
just him and again it was the kind of
thing that was just out there now the
speed at which it developed yesterday
surprised me I don't know why maybe it's
draft week it shouldn't have but it just
seemed like it was an idea a month ago
though that may or may not go somewhere
and then obviously it took off and
exploded yesterday if Brady is still in
New England is drunk out of retirement
I don't believe yes no I think that this
was a situation where if Tom left there
wherever he went
Gronk would have gone if Tom would have
gone to Los Angeles to put for the
Chargers I believe we might be having
this conversation today about Gronk
playing for the Chargers if gamma guante
San Francisco to play for the 49ers I
think Gronk might be playing with George
kiddo
there in the Bay Area wherever he was
going to go
I think Gronk had it in his mind that
he'd be interested in following and you
need no further evidence of that then
going back two years ago to the draft of
2018 right before that draft the
Patriots reached an agreement with the
Lions to trade Gronk to Detroit and they
were gonna trade Gronk in a second-round
pick and get back a second and a
first-round pick which would have given
the Patriots three first-round picks in
2018 and Gronk when he found that he was
going said I'm gonna retire
I'm not going to Detroit don't wanna
play anywhere else but with Tom and so I
think there's the evidence of the
loyalty and
it was going to be Tampa Bay in this
particular case or was going to be
nothing which is why then I think New
England really we're stuck
New England doesn't get stuck often but
in this particular case Gronk had a ten
million dollar salary they only got a
million dollars against the cap if he
says I'm coming back they got a carry
that salary clear the space and make
room for him and they weren't prepared
to do that when he didn't want to do
that could have made life hard for them
and so they took a player that wasn't
gonna play for them and turned it
basically into a fourth round pick
did the Patriots have a good day
yesterday well I don't think it was a
bad day I think it was business as usual
for them I think that they again treated
Gronk in a seven for four so to me
that's about as good as they could do in
that particular case now I guess you're
asking that because there's some people
saying oh boy Tom's gone Gronk gone
people want to leave that kind of thing
yeah I mean it is what is you you think
they care there they don't care they're
going on I got the draft tomorrow they
got 12 picks they're tied with the
Vikings and the Jaguars for the
second-most picks in the draft they're
looking ahead they're not looking back
down there
they're on to the draft do you think
that Belichick cared does he care about
this story other than they got a fourth
round pick and I'm I'm with you on this
I think the Patriots did better I mean
they got something for nothing
yeah and and so I get that but do you
think that Belichick cares about this
situation that those two are reunited I
don't
I think he's so he's so singularly
focused on what he needs to get done and
the draft and the difficult times that
we're all living in and trying to adapt
his organization to where we're at right
now that at the risk of sounding rude
the last thing he's thinking about his
Tom Brady and Rob Gronkowski he couldn't
care less in my life we're talking to
Adam Schefter of course the great
insider he'll be working the draft and
of course his podcast the Adam Schefter
podcast Joe burrow Zach Taylor we had
sac Taylor on and he said you know we're
kind of
in on who we're going to take have they
have they wavered at all has there been
an offer presented to them about going
up to number one
I don't believe they wavered one bit dad
I'm sure people have called and they
have held firm and true to the guy that
they've wanted all along they have not
booked at all they have not wavered at
all not to my knowledge I'm sure they
have gotten some calls and they have
told anybody is who is called to date
thank you very much but no thank you we
are staying where we are and we're gonna
take the quarterback from LSU Joel
burrow and I know that you're you're not
an analyst you're an insider but when
you start to look at what's going on
like you have to be an analyst in
looking at the games that are played
leading up to the draft what is real
what is not you know and I always say
it's a roller coaster ride for every
quarterback and you look each week and
it felt like each quarterback got a week
where we talked about them we praise
them and then we bury them you know
Jordan Love had his week and then you
know it feels like Justin Herbert got
his week and now two is getting a week
that he doesn't want because it's all
negativity here how do you sort out
exactly what is going on with tua
and his camp you know day it's funny say
that because I think of that and every
year we watched it unfold and I think
this is the 30th NFL Draft that I've
covered and you see these guys in a way
they're like stocks their stock is up
one week their stock is down the next
it's up its down and you never quite
know the way it's going to go but rest
be assured during the process almost
everybody outside the number one overall
pick we'll have his stock down at some
point in time no matter how good he is
and so too has gone through that look
and I'm a part of this like I ride that
wave to last week I thought boy Justin
Herbert's going to the Dolphins I think
and now I don't know that I think that
anymore
and I don't know what's right if I'm
going to tell it like it because the
Dolphins have done a great job when you
talk to people they say I say what do
you know they said I know it's very
quiet out of my ass
me my sense today is that the Dolphins
like Jordan love and Toa more than they
like Herbert but do I know that I don't
know that no my god listen that's the
beauty of this trip you know why because
it's the bewitching hour it's the moment
of the truth and everybody's got to put
their cards on the table right like yep
here's the quarterback we like we like
this one we're taking this guy and
there's no hiding it but you also have
people who will yet member when tua was
getting roughed up and then Trent Dilfer
who had been working him out came to his
defense and then it like it's this game
a ping pong with opinions here Boomer
Esiason going after Mike Lombardi
talking about how how could you dare
leaked this information about - oh this
is a smear campaign you know are they
hoping that he gets to New England and
Belichick takes - uh because he's
friends with Saban like there's some
wild bleep going on here that's what the
draft is and always has been and it's a
situation where that I mean it's just
yet teams floating things in an effort
to help themselves you never know if
they're pushing an agenda to try to get
a certain player to a certain spot all
it takes is one Lee
like you hear anonymous medical things
I'll say this medically I never like to
say this just made too much about a guy
before a draft because I don't think
it's fair to the player and I think it
is a situation I'm not telling that that
somebody's gonna say is gonna influence
but maybe it does
maybe it does let the process fall where
it will and then you come out and say
something afterwards about the guy's
medical I remember a few years ago I was
told that Shaq Lawson who was projected
as a first-round pick they get a torn
labrum if my memory serves me correct I
didn't say anything about I just let the
draft unfold and the Buffalo Bills
roundup taking him and I popped on TSP
and I said well Shaq Lawson great player
but there were some teams that are
concerned about his labrum and might
need surgery and the bills came on Rex
was the head coach toothpaste that's not
true doesn't need it and a week later
Shaq Lawson had torn labrum surgery
well I did the NBA draft one year and I
had a an agent from another client a
group of clients come up to me and say I
hope you're gonna bring up you know this
guy's his knee problems he won't last
more than five years in the NBA who was
the guy Paulie drafted by Portland was
Brandon Roy right
and yeah and he did have knee issues but
this agent said I hope you and Billis
are gonna talk about this on the show
that guy won't last five years because
of his need issues listen a lot of times
then where there's smoke there's fire
and it's real sometimes okay but
sometimes it's not and you know what
different guys heal and and and and take
care of their bodies differently and
have chances to throw you just don't
know it depends on where they go how
they have is there's no way it didn't
fully know it's it's really just a dark
throw and seeing what happens but you
know to me just personally with the
injury kind of stuff unless it's you
know obvious out there everyone knows
you know it's some of the quieter I just
like to leave it alone and then when the
guys drafted you go say something about
it I'll leave you with this I was
absolutely dumbfounded that John Lynch
said to Rich Eisen yeah we did a
drive-by with Tom Brady why why say that
because I think people suspected that
they were interested and look I guess
what I would say in response to that is
there are 31 other teams that should
have been having that conversation well
maybe not 31 because Kansas City should
have had it but if you're a quarterback
or you're a team and you got a
quarterback that hasn't been a perennial
Pro Bowl player a future hall-of-fame
guy every single one of those teams
should be discussing as the 49ers did do
we make this move should we make this
move do we go sign Tom and what would
happen with our quarterback what could
we get are we in a better spot now
long-term I just think it's healthy
that's a must lie situation Adam it's a
must lie especially with Garoppolo who's
already you know taking the slings and
arrows here he's already a little
sensitive here I'm gonna guess
and now all of a sudden your coach
doesn't come out and dispel anything
they should have said no we have our guy
we wish Tom well he's always been a
great opponent but we got our guy I'm
not gonna argue with you did I listen to
my point like I said 20 teams should
have had that discussion but I guess
most of them wouldn't admit that they
did no no where are you gonna be
tomorrow exactly where I'm sitting right
my couch my kids screaming for me my
wife saying come take out the garbage
whatever it may be Becky
have you heard about our Tampa Bay
t-shirt situation what is your top a
base situation well we came out with the
t-shirt as soon as Tom announced he was
going to Tampa Bay we came up with tompa
bay made t-shirts not bad you know what
I like better what could we do this now
like can I whisper it to and are you
guys and like we go in together then
sure I can do a red shirt
although if you say it now then you said
it on the air now it's it's it's you
know it's on record yes all good
anything in G ok here we go
but I I like I like the t-shirts the the
Tampa Bay Patriots or the New England
Buccaneers all right another point a
simple I the Tampa Bay treants how about
that I don't think we need to just the
Tampa Patriots I mean that does my money
we don't need to get cute here ok how
about this one
the Gronk in ears I'm sure he likes that
you know well
we're printing up that t-shirt this
morning ok well yeah send something but
you said something me then yeah I'd be
more than happy to okay good now you
strike me as a sleeveless kind of guy
definitely obviously was kind of guy you
know yet like little packs of the hair
growing on I saw Michael Scott you know
in the office in the basketball game and
it struck me as you might be sort of a
Michael Scott like basketball like
support surprisingly jacked
back in the day you know I was the last
guy on my high school basketball team I
wasn't very good but I was a try-hard
I was not talented like you and
basketball you were try hard guy never
very talented but always try hard we'll
get you some t-shirts we got the top of
it but we were told by Tom's
law firm that we have to well I got a
letter yesterday yeah yeah they said we
got to stop selling the t-shirts by the
end I didn't get that yet I think I got
a cease I didn't get the desist yet yeah
but yeah we have to stop selling those
t-shirts but like I said New England
Buccaneers Tampa Bay page it's just it's
simple but effective right won't work
something yeah please do all right have
fun tomorrow and don't tip it thanks for
having me be well and stay safe to you
and everybody out there that's Adam
Schefter
ESPN senior NFL insider